this is honestly this is what I wanted I
want you to know that I'm here to
anything you I can help you with you can
reach me my is my first name dot last
name at gmail.com so Naveen dot Jan at
gmail.com send me an email I read every
single email don't ask me for funding
that's not something I ever do but I'm
happy to help and I don't need anything
in return
so I'm awesome we have a question right
with a question right here let's go
let's go up to the yeah yeah thank you
so I feel like I want to cry like with
what you're talking about it's okay to
cry
it is good to cry you know I I went to
doctors for like ten years over ten
years and there were times that like I
woke up and my leg was numb and I had to
crawl to the kitchen to eat the right
thing and I lived with so much fear and
then I had to become my own doctor and
I'd go to doctors and they'd say like oh
it's a food sensitivity and I was like
well [ __ ] help me right and I I came
to the same conclusion of food as
medicine and and so just I want to say
thank you because of the work that
you're doing like I see my friends like
we have an AI company and blah blah blah
we're doing all this work and I see my
friends who are working in the just like
working for antibiotics and I'm like no
the solution is food if we only
understood that it's [ __ ] food that's
gonna make us better so a few questions
that I have for you are portable what
will have family thank you thank you um
have you found just so many questions
but I'm gonna have two main ones have
you found any patterns within families
is the microbiome between siblings and
parents have you found similarities
where it's like a 20 percent variance
versus me and my friend it's like like a
bigger variance so that's one question
and then the other question is sugar we
understand the harm that sugar is
causing on our brain on our microbiome
can you speak to sugar and
the last question that I have is just
have you also so sure it's on the on the
bad side have you seen any patterns for
the general population on what's good
for everyone is it's like is there
anything that's good across the board is
that you know we've heard greens just
like eat greens and it sounds like that
might not be the answer so those those
three okay what was the first question
yes yeah so yeah so interestingly
the skin microbiome tends to get more
similar with the people who live
together especially the last research
that I saw was when you look at the skin
microbiome especially on the feet they
tend to get very similar between the
people who live together right in the
gut microbiome we in fact found that
even the people who were absolutely
twins their microbiome were completely
different because our microbiome is
influenced by everything right so that
places we go visit the air be inhale the
food we eat and the you know places we
touch please shake hands we shade
everything changes our microbiome
because we touch things it changes our
microbial we eat food that you know
anything we touched even lift the food
that changes our microbiome because no
no so your sister and you probably would
have little bit more similarity there
between you and someone still living in
India right because they're completely
different foods they're eating so the
you know similar types of if you grew up
in a similar environment you literally
were conjoined and you literally went to
the same places ate the same food it
came from you know mom's microbiome mom
it exactly the same food all her life
and did not change her food you know I'm
saying so so many things changes because
your initial microbiome is seeded by
what mom made the mom's microbiome
that's a snapshot of what mom was eating
that during your pregnancy versus her
pregnancy right so all the things are so
different then it's very difficult for
them to be and the one of the
interesting thing is there is no such
thing as a healthy microbiome that's one
a unique healthy microbiome that means
think of your microbiome as a rainforest
every step you take in the rainforest is
completely different ecosystem yet
everything is lush and green that means
you can have gazillions great ecosystem
and what people used to think about was
a good bacteria and the bad bacteria
that was an old philosophy it is about a
good ecosystem or a bad in ecosystem
this is literally they all work together
let me just give you just tiny bit more
on that every one of
is very likely we have ecoli in our gut
we have c-diff in our gut and those are
really interesting they we need them but
all other stuff keeps them in check if
what happens is when we have c-diff and
we end up taking antibiotics and we
throw the nuclear bomb inside a body
it kills whole bunch of that is stuff
and the seed of being more resistant it
takes over and then suddenly we have all
the problems or equal ID but we need
them to keep our immune system pumped up
you need to prime the pump so these
organisms are not constantly priming our
immune system next time the pathogen
comes the immune system say whatever so
these guys are there to essentially keep
the immune system ready to go so you
need this whole ecosystem that is good
or bad producing the right set of
nutrients and not producing this enough
of the thing that are actually causing
the gut lining to share the biggest
problem we face right now is you know
the way our food is processed and the
where food is grown so all the stuff
that you probably saw the glyphosate the
last you guys see it
Monsanto just lost two hundred and fifty
three million dollar to just single
person because they showed that how in
the weed killer the glyphosate thing is
causing the gut microbiome to completely
decimate and they sue them and they one
two hundred fifty three million dollar
and their million more lawsuits coming
now right then god because somebody's
gotta stop nice things right so other
things so my point is that our food
causes the gut microbiome to change
antibiotics so don't think of good or
bad bacteria think of the bacteria being
actually health at the ecosystem healthy
and there is not one healthy state there
can be multiple healthy states because
we can have different organisms
producing nutrients that our body needs
second question you asked me was so it's
generally in general sugar is good for
bad for everyone
general there is no one can you know
it's needed so don't get me wrong
without sugar is the easiest thing for
our energy to be produced so we reign
universe although that sugar is general
my point is anything you eat eventually
is going to get converted into sugar
because our brain needs right so you eat
carbs is going to go back and convert
into the glucose so my point is
additional sugar is something that is
just too much sugar is bad for you but
it's not that you don't stop because you
can't eat anything mean carbohydrates
are basically sugar right so anything
you eat broccoli is carbohydrate it has
to there so there is nothing you can eat
that doesn't have right so my point is
not that you can avoid what I'm access
sugar is bad for everyone because it
just causes additional insulin
additional insulin basically makes it
insulin resistance that causes more
inflammation and blah blah blah
okay so we had a third question was is
there anything that's generally good for
everyone and the answer is if you're
going to simply follow general
guidelines all I can say is there's no
such thing as universal healthy food
however if you're going to do anything
and not gonna do any test anything the
more colors you can eat more diversity
of food you can eat that means eat as
many different types of food as you can
eat more seasonal stuff as in the season
don't eat the stuff that's out of season
I mean those are generally the good
rules to follow which is but then again
it could be the stuff spinach or you
know any of the stuff could be aren't
harming you like almonds who would have
thought other words would be bad for
right you know I can tell you that for
me the biggest change for me came from
initially the first time and at the test
the things that are bad for me was his
spinach avocado and oats and I when I
changed my diet after six months I can
eat his spinach avocado notes and the
three bad things were me were almonds
and daily
and now and soya because I start eating
you know guess what happened when I cut
down all that stuff what were they
eating lot of tofu a lot of the stuff
that I was eating now those things I was
feeding those organisms became so much
suddenly the ecosystem bad back bad
again now I need to cut down on very
almonds and soil because you know soya
has not just estrogen it has something
that produces tea ma you microorganisms
take that stuff and convert them into T
ma are tri methyl s acetylene and when
you go up that T ma gets absorbed in the
body and it your liver converts them
into T ma o which causes the heart
disease so I had massive amount of tea
ma and normally the T ma comes from a
carnitine so if you eating red meat and
I'm a vegetarian and I could not figure
out why I have such high tea ma until we
realized I would be doing so much tofu
and that's where the tea ma was coming
from and you need to get this every
couple of months then so the idea is
when you are sick or when you're trying
to recover from something it is good to
check every three or four months because
your body is constantly changing and
once you get to a good spot maybe you
can check every six months and when you
get to really good spot maybe you can do
once a year but it's like a car my car
is not even complex and you still Andrew
tune it every year and if you don't tune
your car you end up in a repair shop
which for the humans called emergency
room so first of all thank you so much
to me this is an amazing talk very
enlightening so just as a marketer my
question for you is everything you're
saying makes so much sense why doesn't
everyone know this is it a disbelief or
is it just not enough people saying the
right things so many things first of all
no one has incentive to say that right
the people know about drugs because they
spend billions of dollars in advertising
the drugs on television you know take
this drug and you're wonderful and then
they spend two minutes telling you about
you can become important blah blah blah
blah blah
and nobody hears that right and then
suddenly happy family look at this right
and you know so no one has incentive to
propagate food because no one makes
money from it the good thing is I could
have spent a lot of money in marketing
this then the cost of that would be
substantially higher so we spend zero
money in marketing so we can keep the
cost as low as possible I want to bring
this cause down to under $100 and I
really believe in the next couple of
years I could do that so we brought them
from thousand to 399 now to 299 and I'm
hoping in the next three to four months
I will bring it down to $1.99 and I want
to really bring it down to under $100
within the 12 months up to 18 months and
that will happen and it happens two
reasons the volume makes the things
happen second thing is exponential
technologies everything that I need is
on exponential curve sequencing cost is
gonna come down the Amazon cost is gonna
come down and some time I just bad I
went to Amazon and said please help me I
can't I can't afford to pay you $40 per
person analyzing the data so sometimes
they know okay fine we'll give you a
discount and same thing I meant you know
the Amin's and I said I can't sell this
thing I don't know how to market it
would you buy it from me and salad
and now we're going to be actually if
they never do that but you know I got
them excited about the mission we are on
and I'm just telling me this a fact is I
asked the guide I say imagine would Jeff
Bezos legacy will be as the richest man
in the world or his legacy gonna be that
he helped me solve the chronic disease
problems right and now I hope we are
hopeful that we're going to become a
vendor to Amazon when we don't have to
sell they're gonna sell it for us so
point is rien be a great scientist but
we are really shitty marketeers I mean
that's what it is I mean we don't know
how to buy Facebook Ads we don't even
know how to go do these things if you
were really good at it we'll be selling
this you know you know a snake why like
other people do thank you so please help
me if you're good at it
[Music]
yes doing here thank you so much I I
really liked the idea of talking to
people about the world that I imagine
and one day I imagine that I'm gonna be
sitting in a seat like yours and someone
is going to be looking up to me for
hopefully things that I've done in the
future
and when someone asks me you know how I
dealt with all the adversity that I'm
dealing with now I'm wondering if you
have some advice that I could tell the
next person yeah so I mean so the
adversity comes in many shapes and sizes
so first of all I never get anxious or
stressed
it doesn't matter what is happening
around me and two reasons for that I
don't worry about the things that I
can't control
it's not in my control I don't worry
about it and I never worry about the
thing that I in my control because I
know I'm doing the best I possibly can
and that's really the things so coming
from the eastern philosophy my belief
really is I don't focus on the outcome I
focus on the actions I take and in you
know in gita it talks about all I have
to do is to take the action and outcome
will be what will be and that is really
the best way of dealing with adversity
is to say I can't change the world
around me only thing I can change is how
I react to it right so happiness is a
choice happiness is not something that
someone gives you it's a choice you make
every day when you get up in the morning
you can have ten reasons why you should
be happy and you can come up with the
ten reasons why your life really sucks
it doesn't matter who you are and you
can make that choice any day happiness
has to be something that is inherent in
you if you are an unhappy person you can
go to the most beautiful place in the
world
you bring unhappiness with you you're
still be unhappy when you are a happy
person you could be sitting in a dark
corner and it still the happiness is
with you no one can make you happy the
problem that happens is we always say oh
my girlfriend makes me happy my you know
my you know spouse makes me happy the
fact is that they make you happy you're
given the remote control of your
happiness to them they're happy unhappy
happy unhappy when you are happy inside
you share that happiness with everyone
but you they don't control your
happiness and that's where you need to
be learn to fall in love with yourself
every woman I see actually suggests that
most girls have hardest time with this
all in love with yourself and I don't
mean being self-conceited simply don't
look for approval from anyone else the
self love is the biggest thing you can
give yourself don't require someone's
approval don't care what anyone thinks
do the things that you believe are right
what you want what you love and if
someone disapproves of it just look at
anything your life you live your life I
live my life and it's amazing how
amazing things happen when you do that
you got to be who you are and you got to
fall in love with who you are
let's go over here first right here yeah
I mean I've been following you for quite
some time now
and I've heard your podcast on Tom boo
you and school of greatness so I think
my question is you've I think educated
all of us here on Rockets the supply
chain of rocket science is using GoPros
in Mike you know microbiomes and all
these things how do you manage to moon
shot in all these areas is it you
dedicating like a period of few years in
each of these areas do you dedicate how
do you spend your days you know like how
do you break up your week how does your
day look like and how can we aim to
moonshot in these different areas so the
the couple of question I'm gonna give a
very specific answer to them for exactly
one generally the wrong question to ask
is you know most people tend to say hey
tell me what are your habits when what
are you doing and to me that's really
the what I would say is yes stupid
question to ask is probably that's what
I say and here's why you never want to
know someone's habits you want to know
their mindset and here's why Tony
Robbins take ice baths every day you can
take ice baths three times a day and
you're not gonna become Tony Robbins
ever you're gonna become Tony Robbins by
thinking like Tony Robbins so now I'm
gonna come back and I'll show you a
question so what I do is every time I
want to start a company in any industry
I don't spend years what I do is I read
about at least a dozen book on that
subject and here is why if I only read
one book the author's view becomes my
view when I read 15 books I get 15
different point of views and my point of
view added to that becomes completely
unique because I'm able to synthesize
all things in they all looking at the
trees and by looking at the 15 tree that
can able look at the whole forest then
one thing I you know I specifically do
is in
each one of the industry I go to my
Twitter feed and I set up a feed only
for just that industry so if you look at
my news feed for today it will be about
every single research that comes out of
a microbiome I in the morning I get up
at 4 a.m. and the first two to three
hours I read everything and then I have
a news feed that's about every single
science stuff in every industry that is
happening so I spent two hours and
specific and then one hour across
because that allows me to keep
collecting the dots then I keep
collecting the dots sometime I see the
missing god I said aha now I can solve
the problem the fact I was reading that
says the bacteria have autofluorescence
so when this guy is telling me about
Hubble telescope and how they're able to
detect the smallest faintest light I am
thinking bacteria right and that would
have never happened unless I was reading
all the different stuff so I'm able to
apply the knowledge from the nanotech
apply that to and see how that would
change what I'm doing here was there any
other question there I think it was
mostly around how do you get deep you
know I think a lot of people have
surface level knowledge and you know it
could be by reading a book or two like
ha I think that's the question is how do
you get so one thing I would suggest to
everyone here to get the farm you can
never go deep in something unless you
have a foundational knowledge of various
subjects because then the deep thing
starts to make sense right so to me the
biggest change that came to me was when
I started to learn at I went to
singularity University and really
understood the foundational knowledge of
every single subject so when I read a
scientific journal I may not get a lot
out of it but I see I see I kind of
understand what is going on and that is
what allows me to say ok I don't
understand what this DMA thing is but
there is something going on here that is
similar to what I thought was matter of
a light and I'm gonna go next time I
read something I said oh I read about
that TM 18 now I understand what
and that's really is to get the broad
foundational knowledge and some there
two things you can do go to youtube and
go look for the singularity university
things and then you go watch bunch of
videos other thing is go to ted that
talks and watch modules and this really
is what i actually end up getting the
broad knowledge and then each subject I
go read bunch of books so there were
three years I spent just reading about
cancer I spent two years just reading
about books on neuroscience then I ran
the books on just on genetics it's just
because I'm curious and that's really
what I do I just go and stay there was
one time I had you know several dozen
books just sitting on neuroscience and
I'm just a crazy guy I can never read
candle so I buy physical books and
another good thing I used to buy
physical books every and all my children
used to laugh at me and say dad someday
you're gonna start reading them other
things what I realized was when I buy
the physical book I leave them on the
table and I always see when I come home
he's reading it and I never told them
why I do that I kept telling okay if I
was on the Kindle they would never but
the fact they were sitting there
somebody will always pick it up and read
it and that was my motive you made this
really profound point just about having
so many different perspectives most of
the time we get locked into one or two
or even just three perspectives on some
issue but with that multidisciplinary
approach and with having so many
different perspectives I think that
really really makes really strong
character in people I'm moving you said
something earlier that really resonated
with me which was were we're trained
from a very young age to become
specialists or have depth in a
particular field and I've personally
what you said resonated with me because
I've learned that it's it's breath that
gives you the upper hand or the
advantage versus depth these days and
it's that it's it's that ability to
connect dots between domains because
people are tapping domains out you get
marg diminishing marginal utility and
domains and so when you can intersect
it's like food you bring two new
ingredients together you get a brand new
food so I really believe in that and the
other thing you said was you know one of
the inspirations for volume was your
father and one of the inspirations for
my company which I was telling you a
little bit earlier was my mother she was
diagnosed with stage four B cancer and
it was abrupt and it it was you know
this is the healthcare system we live in
it's you're fine you're fine you're fine
you're fine than binary you're Stage
four B cancer and so my point is that
anyone who's been through cancer has
been a caregiver in cancer one of the
things they do during treatment at each
chemo if it's IV chemotherapy standard
of cares they check your blood count
before each chemo to make sure you can
handle it and my uncle from London had
come and gave her this very strict
dietary regimen and you would think with
each successive chemo you know her chemo
would drop and they'd have to give her
some some stimulants for that her blood
count she was getting healthier during
chemo which is really strange and it was
I really believe it was because of the
diet not the drugs and so just a
testament to what you were saying is
that you know I've lost faith any faith
that I had left in Pharma that sometimes
the old way of natural foods and the
right type of food can be way more
efficacious than thank you all this
complex science hey thank you for being
here tonight and I love how you talk
about finding the root cause so my
question for you is from a personal
angle and caring about our entire world
I'm like a start-up founder grinding
really hard no money would love to
Ford biome if I could afford it but I
don't have the money for it so what do
you think I'm happy to give it to you I
mean seriously if you can't afford it
just it's on me oh thank you
what what do you think is the root cause
of poverty or not having enough money so
I mean there are a lot of things I mean
to me the power P is simply a symptom
it's not a disease and it comes from
many things one is really the idea of
family structure and I would say
education so to large extent you look at
the stuff that I grew up in the poverty
and the only reason I'm not there is
because my mother believed that we can
break the cycle and only we we build the
cycle was through education so even
though I did not for the longest time
knew my mother was illiterate
I remember that when I was small she
will wake me up at 5:00 a.m. and she
will say she will point on the thing and
she tell me the answer to that problem
and I would say mom the answer is nine
and she was it don't make me look good
again and I will go do it again and I
did not realize that she couldn't even
read but she cared she cared so there
was a family structure and as she cared
and she gave me the education and that
was the cycle out of the poverty right
so one thing is a family that cares
ninety percent of the time the reason
people stay in poverty is because they
are broken families parents are the most
one cares what is going on no one gives
love to me one of the things we did was
it's were hard you know it coming from
poverty is easy our children grew up in
very affluent family how did we give
them the values it was very interesting
you will see so just if I could just
brag most of you can do with my oldest
son is now 28 and if you google his name
is uncle a and K you are if you just
google him he was 17 when he started
Kairos Society ka i ro s and his world's
largest College on
thing started a company when he
graduated from water sold the company
and now he's focused on helping young
entrepreneurs to solve real-world
problems affordable housing senior care
for our daughter graduated from Stanford
she de Stanford Mayfield Fellows 10-4
his temper she's the board of his turn
for women in business and all she wanted
to do was solve the problem of gender
equality she is running a company at PI
matrix which essentially uses AI to
remove the gender bias and highly
our youngest one is senior at Stanford
the fact is what is it that they did
what we did they didn't have to work
they knew they had plenty of money they
could and they are all driven they work
if you look at uncle just watch he's on
CNBC at least once a week he's on Wall
Street Journal full page if you pick up
the entrepreneur magazine this month he
has six pages spread on it right I mean
he's everywhere because from the young
days we told them that our love for you
is unconditional you never have to worry
about do we love you but our approval is
not then that was a difference that
approval you have to earn every day but
you love you never have to that means I
will never tell you I'm proud of you
unless you do something that makes us
proud but it will always tell me we love
you and one of the rules that I always
follow and I've never broken it doesn't
matter what I am doing if they call I
take that call and that was my way of
letting them know there is nothing more
important to me when they call and it's
very interesting and a total story I can
tell you that I was running a public
company company was worth very you know
highly valued I am at Goldman Sachs
conference presenting in front of 5,000
investors and my phone rang and I said
it's my son I have to take the call it
was a short call and I said I promised
him that I'll always take his call and I
I did call lasted no more than 15 20
seconds stop moved up by five billion
dollars yes here is a man who makes a
promise and keeps the promise and didn't
give a [ __ ] what we thought he didn't
care what we thought he did what he said
he was going to do and that's a
character that they invested it and my
point is in terms of children it is
simply about letting them know what
makes you proud of them and they will
tell you whatever but they remember that
makes you part of it
and that's what I told them and they
were young go do something that will
change the lives of millions of people
and he told me whatever there and then
he went on to start the Kairos society
because he knew he said dad you asked me
to do that I'm doing and that's mine so
it's that simple so coming out of
poverty is family somebody who can put
the family together create the community
together that is really the way out of
poverty and education and I mean
obviously believing belief is such a
strong thing when you believe you can
you will you have to believe it's
possible dream so big that people think
you're crazy and never be afraid to fail
you only feel when you give up
everything else is just a pivot you put
it you never fail you only feel when you
give up sure go in the middle first
that's fine
go ahead go ahead
Naveen thanks for being here just three
questions there short first one is how
have you found clarity and to how do we
trickles no have you tried meditation I
know you mentioned researching knowledge
what my second question is what's
stopping you from calling Mark
Zuckerberg stone about your project and
you know can you help me with the
marketing sure might be want to help and
lastly how is our privacy protected
volume you know what's stopping it
so I don't think you would do it but you
from you know selling that information
to someone to monetize so the first
question in terms of finding clarity so
I mean of these no doubt the you know
meditation will helps and to me it is my
clarity comes from the thought that
a strong belief in what I am doing and a
strong belief that this problem needs to
be solved it also comes from the fact
that I am similarly focused on the
problem
I am so laser focused sometime
my wife will tell me that I can't even
see things around me that are happening
because I just the world around me
didn't exist when I am focused when I'm
here nothing around me matters to me
that what I'm doing right now living
every minute of it
as if it's my last minute I never worry
about what happened could have happened
should have happened would have happened
I never worry about what will happen it
doesn't that I simply focus on what I
need to do right now and hope that can
change the trajectory of the future
second question you asked me was about
mark calling Mark Zuckerberg and that
Jeff you know so interesting thing is I
first of all I just don't have it in me
to ask him for something yet and I
probably will if I meet him sometime I
will it so happened his sister used to
work for myself a long time so yes I can
always get to get to him but if you do
know him let him know that I need have
third thing is on privacy so first thing
you know the first thing we always keep
all the personally identifiable data
from the data second thing is the thing
we collect is really a snapshot of what
is happening unlike a DNA that from the
time you're born to time you die your
same DNA it is a snapshot of what's
happening inside your gut even if
someone to beat the [ __ ] out of you by
that time they get the [ __ ] it will be
completely different from what I saw so
they will still want to know it's the
same person right so it's I mean in all
seriousness I mean we don't have any
desire to sow the data because we're not
trying to figure out how to optimize the
most amount of money if I was trying to
optimize the thing our
four thousand dollars right now instead
of you know the ad cost that weekend
yeah so um I I really resonate with when
you mentioned about education being away
out of poverty you know I've been I've
seen I haven't been in poverty myself
that I've seen a lot of it I've done
disaster relief work before another
thing I've seen you know where education
was the way out of poverty for people
but one thing I mean you know that
always bogs me down is in the world of
poverty there's also this resource that
time that people just don't have
I've seen people children you know who
need to work on the farms day in and day
out they can't go to school because
they're you know families need to eat
I've seen you know people who are you
know powdery America they need to work
on weekends and nights they need to work
two jobs three jobs they don't have time
to read books and learn what are your
thoughts on how we can give the time to
these people want anyway supership well
you know first of all all of those
things are true so none of the things
I'm gonna take away but the good thing
is the technology is becoming so
powerful that today you can learn things
while you're working right so in some
sense a lot of gamification and the
stuff that is done on the devices that
cost a few dollars now right so you can
buy a Android tablets for under $10 now
and people are able to share them in
villages people be able to hear the
lesson side so one of the things that
Ellen was referring to is that there is
a project that XPrize has is a complete
literacy project that means from it
someone who is completely illiterate who
has never seen anything to be able to
get to read write a mat in under
eighteen months and that is project now
being tested in 80 different legit in
Africa so I really believe that you know
the prolific ation of cell phones and
devices are happening so fast that these
are the devices that
really become the mechanism for
education anything is changing so I hope
it comes faster and even the fact that
now you are able to have broadcast that
means it's no reason you couldn't
broadcast the information or lecture
while they are working on the fields
so I really hope that over time those
things will change and but the
interesting thing is for the first time
that we no longer just a consumer of
information but we are also the producer
of ideas and as producer of ideas are
sharing those ideas so a idea in a
village in Africa can be shared by for a
person in village in India that was
never possible before so in some sense
the idea that is spreading faster and
faster and knowledge is spreading faster
and faster so we will leave these
problems will get solved and the only
other thing I can possibly add to this
is that even the definition of poverty
is changing even today I would argue the
poorest person has more resources than
the richest person had 108 years ago so
whatever that means right and the fact
that as we are looking at the world with
the exponential technologies many of the
things that we used to have value will
be demonetised
that means you don't have to anymore
work for food or water or shelter
because all those things will be taken
care of because they will be the truly
free all right what a really powerful
Q&A session Naveen ik yeah and just I
really am it's amazing to learn more
about who you are and why you're doing
what you're doing and how you're
inspiring people to take those next big
steps those risks those moonshots and do
it for a perspective of bringing utility
and great value to the world thank you
for giving me your time because that's I
know it's valuable to you you could be
doing any number of things but the fact
we chose to give me your time I thank
you for it and I hope I was able to give
you something that you could possibly
say that was worth your time but if you
think of anything just know you can
reach out to me any time and if there is
anything I can do to help you you have
my heart and soul thank you
sure sure very quick very quick please
ambition how do we I get frustrated
sometimes because right like we have
this one life and and I wake up every
day and I'm like let's go there's
important [ __ ] we have to get done but
how do we how do we teach people drive
an ambition and hunger like like why
isn't everyone waking up in this way of
like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] it's like we have
one life why aren't we trying to solve
real problems why are we building apps
that are just like games like how do we
teach that so first thing is you know
change the environment you live in in my
world if you're not in that world or
wake up in the morning and by the way I
tell that to every single person who
works for me I always tell them when you
wake up in the morning and you don't
jump out call me I promise you I will
find you a job that pays as much or more
and you have that on me that I will find
you a job that you did excited about you
jump out of a bad if this is not for you
that's totally fine
so surround yourself with people what
just as passionate and create a
community of people that essentially
will make you better when you surround
yourself with people that are bringing
you down then you're gonna always be
struggling because they suck the energy
out of you you want to be around people
that when you wake up at 4 and say you
know what did I tell you what I did at
3:30 and that's really the kind of
people you want to surround yourself
with so all I say is go out and kick
some ass and have some fun
well thank you very much again and and I
hope let's have some fun and we'll be
together hopefully we'll get to continue
to have this dialogue and stick around
and network with each other after the
event for a little while there's still
some more drinks and conversation to be
had I want to thank everybody for coming
out thank you for your city and thank
you what why did the person this to
listening yes Richard stone the bank it
thank you work wise for hosting us and
Devine for coming out this has been a
huge pleasure thank you sir thank you
and yes and thank you guys for coming
out here
couple couple quick things if you want
to come we have an aggro that's
happening it's our first Agora this is
just a it's a it's a way to connect the
dots we have so many brilliant people
that are building the future in
different disciplines and what better
way to figure out how they can work
together than to host an amazing event
here at work wise on September 20th on
Thursday where we're gonna have all
those different disciplines here for fun
evening of networking then on the 28th
we're gonna be hosting a women in
Alliance event here so we're gonna have
a couple very powerful women that are
building futures here joining us on
stage and talking about what is going on
in the world and what they're working on
so check us out all that information can
be found at simulation series com
and lastly just go build the future much
love everyone thank you
[Applause]